hi everyone and welcome i hope you're
enjoying google cloud next 21 i know
this is another virtual year but i'm
hoping that today i get to bring some of
my experiences to life for you
i'm going to be talking about what it
was like to explore the six layers of
google cloud data center security
now you might be thinking of lasers
night vision cameras and military grade
fences
you're not too far off because security
is one of the most critical elements of
our data center's dna and google cloud
workloads with dozens of data centers
globally security operations means
managing a massively complex network
i was one of the rare googlers to visit
one
so i'm going to take you on a journey to
the core of a data center to show you
the six layers of physical security
designed to thwart unauthorized access
but first i'll touch on google cloud
security philosophy before i take you on
that journey to the core of the data
center and then we'll touch on how you
can leverage that same philosophy on
google cloud
and it's great to be here today my name
is stephanie wong i'm a cloud developer
advocate and i've been creating
developer-focused content for the last
four years or so here of course when i
got the chance to visit a data center
and make a film about it i jumped at the
opportunity so let's go ahead and dive
right into it
so in terms of transparency we're very
clear about our commitments to customers
about your data rule number one your
data belongs to you no one else we do
not sell customer data to third parties
nor do we use it for advertising your
data is your data your data is also
encrypted in transit and at rest all
times and you do not have to ask for
that and if you want we can give you
ways to add additional encryption on top
of that
we also have explicit rules to guard
against insider access
there is no back door to google there's
no secret government access we take
pride in our international audits and we
deliver results on request
these are the most important roles in
our mission of digital transformation
it's giving you the trust that you need
to build great things
so how can google cloud help
organizations with their security
well first we provide protection from
threats through a secure foundation core
infrastructure that is designed built
and operated with security in mind
second we provide customers with a
constantly expanding array of controls
that they can use to help meet policy
regulatory and business objectives
and third we work to meet our compliance
responsibilities and provide
capabilities to make complaints easier
for customers
but first let's talk about the
protection that you get from building on
our infrastructure foundation
our infrastructure doesn't rely on any
single technology to make it secure
rather we build security through
progressive layers that deliver true
defense in depth
so our hardware is google controlled
built and hardened any application
binary that runs on our infrastructure
is deployed securely
we do not assume any trust between
services and we use multiple mechanisms
to establish and maintain trust our
infrastructure was designed to be
multi-tenant from the start
all identities users and services are
strongly authenticated data stored on
our infrastructure is automatically
encrypted at rest and distributed for
availability and reliability
any communications over the internet to
our cloud services are also encrypted
and the scale of our infrastructure
allows us to absorb many denial of
service attacks we have multiple layers
of protection that further reduce the
risk of any ddos impact
and finally our operations teams detect
threats and respond to incidents 24 7
365 days a year we actually have a white
paper written on our infrastructure
design that goes into all of these areas
in much more detail other cloud
providers might describe a similar stack
of capabilities but the way that google
cloud approaches many of these in my
opinion is very unique
so i had the chance to visit a data
center in 2019 and i made a video about
my experience that you should all check
out i'll be sure to share the link but
you can find it at bit.lee six layers
deep
this was a huge project and it wasn't
easy to get approvals or even step foot
inside the premises
but in my job at google you know i spend
my days working with developers our data
centers are crucial to the work that
they do but most never actually set foot
inside a data center so as you can see
here there is a huge amount of space
that our data centers span
352 000 square feet or 33 000 square
meters
and all in all less than one percent of
googlers ever get to set foot inside
so i was determined to make a video
because for close to two decades google
has designed data centers from the
ground up
security has surfaced as one of the most
critical elements of our dna and it's
part of our commitment to keep our
customers data safe
and not to mention google cloud now
meets more than 45 regulatory
requirements and growing
our products regularly undergo
independent verification of their
security privacy and compliance controls
achieving certifications attestations of
compliance or audit reports against
these global standards
this means that an independent auditor
has examined the controls present in our
data centers infrastructure and
operations these certifications include
some of the most widely recognized
internationally accepted independent
security standards including iso iec
27001 for security controls iso iec
27017
for cloud security and iso iec 27018 for
cloud privacy as well as aicp sock one
two and three these certifications are
helping us meet the demands of the
industry standards like csa star and pci
dss as well as many other regional
standards as well we continue to expand
our list of compliance offerings
globally to assist our customers with
their compliance obligations
so
while auditors can sometimes enter our
data centers to perform these audits
most people including googlers cannot
under special authorization i found out
that our physical data center security
is built using that defense in depth
foundation it's made up of six layers
from the exterior all the way to the
center
each increasing in controls as you get
to layer six
so i'm going to walk through each layer
and some of the most notable features
and experiences that i went through
so let's start with layer one
this is the secure perimeter basically
it means the property boundaries and
that includes all the signage and
fencing around the property these are
the furthest most exterior edges of the
property so as you drive into the
property you'll see signs that might
have a google logo or a signage but
otherwise you really can't tell
immediately that it's a data center it's
more or less looks like an industrial
area or a business park
but things really start to get
interesting when it comes to layer two
also known as the secure perimeter and
that includes the main entrance gate
so i started my journey by driving up to
this gate at which point i needed my
credentials and my identity checked even
before stepping foot into the property
boundaries i was already on an access
approval list
the least privileged protocol is the
idea that someone should have only the
bare minimum privileges necessary to
perform their job
so if your least privilege is to enter
layer two then you're not gonna have
luck moving to layer three
each person's access and permissions are
checked at badge readers starting with
layer one and progresses more
stringently at layer six
these exist at every access point in the
data center facility and authorization
measures happen everywhere using this
protocol this is something that we don't
just employ in a data center but it's
also a best practice we always recommend
for how you set up your organization
resources and data on google cloud so as
you know applying least privilege to iam
roles on google cloud is recommended so
any user has the bare minimum roles and
their permissions to perform their
functions
so layer 2 has a lot of security
features ranging from smart fencing to
overlapping cameras to 24 7 guard
patrols and more and there's actually a
lot more technology and operations going
on behind the scenes than meets the eye
so from the time that you're on site
they already know that you're there but
what i found also interesting is that
they're able to do correlation analysis
of where you've been on site through
cameras badge access tracking etc and
there are also guards in vehicles and
some guards on foot
as you can see here there's also the
vehicle crash barrier this is designed
to stop a fully loaded truck from
crashing through the front entrance
this particular black fence also that
you see here is an anti-climb fence so
there are spikes pointed outward it'd be
pretty hard to get over that in one
piece
it's also equipped with fiber the
technology tells data center security
operations if someone's near the fence
or touches the fence
they also use thermal cameras and
standard cameras so that they're able to
see video footage at night just as
clearly as they can during the day
each camera overlaps the area that it
can cover so there's no blind spots
anywhere around the data center
now you might be wondering well what if
somebody skydives into the property or
digs under the ground trust me they have
enough coverage of the area that they
will detect something coming into the
property or motion that's occurring near
the fence
these are not only physical safeguards
but act as a big deterrent to anyone
even thinking about trying to forcibly
come inside
and more obstacles await them inside
and we have additional operational
monitoring happening in any case that
will alert more guards to take action if
they detect something
layer three is building access in this
case i was able to enter the lobby but
just so you know this is still nowhere
near the data center floor because
that's still a few more layers deep
so let's say that you've gotten through
the gate you've come inside
you've come into this care lobby and you
have your card or a form of
identification which is checked by a
receptionist to make sure that you're on
the access control list
but what happens if you lose your card
then what
for that reason biometric scanning is
also employed so yes i did have to get
my irises scanned similar to concepts in
software development biometric scanning
is for authentication of identity
meanwhile my badge allowing access to a
certain area is authorization
yes this also felt like i was on some
sort of secret top mission maybe mission
impossible or maybe ocean's 11 or more
recently i've been hearing it's been
compared to professor from money heist
but you know once that was taken care of
another rule exists at the data center
that prevents a vehicle or individual
closely following another to gain entry
into a restricted area without a badge
swipe
so if the system detects a door open for
too long it immediately alerts security
personnel any gate or door must close
before the next vehicle or the person
can badge in and then gain access
you've probably seen dual authentication
when you try to sign into an account and
you get a one-time password sent to your
phone
we take a similar approach at the data
centers to verify a person's identity
and access
at some layers in the data center you're
required to swipe your badge and then
enter a circle lock or tubular doorway
you walk into the special half portal
that checks your badge and scans your
eyes to gain access to the next layer of
the data center it prevents anyone from
closely following you through because
only one person is allowed into the
circle lock at a time
so you can see here that i have to first
badge then step inside get my iris to
scan and then it verifies my identity
and the door on the other side unlocks
and something not shown in the video
that i made is the facility loading
docks which are a special section of
layer 3. they're used to receive and
send shipments of materials like new
hardware
truck deliveries from vendors must be
approved for access to layer 3 to enter
the dock
for security the loading dock room is
physically isolated from the rest of the
data center and a guard is present
a guard presence is required when a
shipment is received or sent i actually
got super lucky when i was there and got
to witness shipments being made of new
servers being delivered and in order for
them to even get to layer three they had
to have been on the allowed access list
through layers one and two
before arriving at layer three
guards checked their identification and
the access list before letting them into
layer two and subsequently opening the
garage door to let them back up into the
loading dock room
then out came fresh new server racks one
by one
and once unloading was complete the
vendor left and the hardware operations
team began to move the racks into layer
four by badging themselves in one at a
time with the actual hardware going into
the data center badge checks occur at
every entry point throughout the
facility to ensure least privilege is
adhered to
even timed authorizations happen so you
can do your job for only an allotted
amount of time
so this could apply to loading docks or
even performing hardware maintenance on
the data center floor
you're probably thinking of your
favorite movie wondering you know what
if supply chain gets intercepted
well additional checks happen for this
potential risk and we have tested for
many potential risk scenarios which i'll
talk about in a little bit
layer four is once you've actually
entered the data center itself and this
includes an extremely important part of
data center security the security
operations center or sock a hive of
activity that's monitoring the data
center 24 7 365 days a year
the doors the cameras the badge readers
the iris scan everything is monitored
from here
anyone on site at the facility will have
their movement patterns tracked
throughout the property via their badge
and biometric scans at entry points and
doors if a door is kept open for too
long or correlation analysis finds that
their presence is in an unauthorized
location alerts will be sent to the sock
instantly
this is like the brains of the security
system so if there's anything out of the
ordinary happening they have to be able
to pick that up
the socks of all google data centers are
also designed to roll up to a regional
sock for multi-regional high
availability purposes
if an on-site sock were to be disrupted
due to an event such as a natural
disaster or emergency building
evacuation
monitoring instantly rolls over to the
regional sock for continuous
uninterrupted monitoring
socks act as a center for emergency and
safety response in addition to security
responsibilities these socks monitor and
respond to alarms at all of our
facilities and are constantly tracking
local and global events that could
impact operations at our data centers
think of this like high availability for
physical security and really
that also means it's high availability
for logical security and data protection
as well
layer 5 is the data center floor
servers and network equipment that power
google live here
security in this layer is one of the
most highly restrictive as it's where
the data resides and this meant i needed
to enter a circle log get my irises
scanned and badge checked and then once
in there i was accompanied by our guards
in every space and the vp of global data
centers joe cava took me around
so only hardware operations personnel
security professionals and key people
granted access on an ads needed basis
can enter
access is limited to the time required
to complete the necessary job function
so this is truly an as needed only
access area meaning that only the
technicians and engineers that have to
be there to maintain upgrade or repair
the equipment are ever allowed there
this layer is protected by a circle lock
as i mentioned security staff and badge
protected doors and the data center
floor features laser beam intrusion
detection additional cameras are also
placed throughout the area while
security staff monitor the data center
floor at all times
and the technicians who have access to
the devices are there but the data at
rest is encrypted and you can also issue
and keep your own encryption keys
and if you're wondering googlers do not
have access to the data unless you've
authorized it for a technical issue and
this is called access transparency which
is a technical control it produces
immutable logs any time a google
administrator needs to enter a
customer's tenant to perform something
whether it's a support request or
maintenance and
you control what types of access that
you want to permit for example
maintenance is okay support's not or
it's okay for a given set of your
environment so layer six is disk
destroyal or as i like to call it hard
drive graveyard
so google employs a strict equipment
chain of custody monitoring meaning that
we meticulously track the location and
the status of all equipment within our
data center this means that we track the
location and status of every hard drive
from acquisition to destruction using
barcodes and asset tags
these asset tags are scanned throughout
a hard drive's lifecycle in a data
center from the time that it's installed
to the time that it's removed from
circulation
and tracking these hard drives closely
ensures that they don't go missing or
end up in the wrong hands
we also make sure hard drives are
properly functioning by doing frequent
performance tests if a component fails
to pass a performance test then it's
deemed no longer usable so to prevent
any sensitive information from living on
that disk then we remove it from
inventory to be erased and destroyed in
layer six disk arrays
disks enter layer six through a secure
two-way locker system allowing only
authorized personnel to retrieve it in
layer six which you're seeing here
when a hard drive is erased and retired
the disk erase formatter uses a zero
filling method that wipes the disk data
and replaces each bit of data with zeros
and we try to recycle drives and their
components but if a drive can't be
erased then it's stored securely until
it can be physically destroyed as you
can see here and it'd be pretty
impossible to recover any data from
these drives
and even if anyone tried to take
anything out of the data center floor
with them we also have metal detectors
and video surveillance to ensure all
personnel exiting the data center halls
are properly checked to prevent
unauthorized equipment from leaving the
floor
if you're wondering what happens to this
waste we actually have researchers in
google's oklahoma facility who are
looking into methods of collecting and
recycling rare earth metals in hard
drives
data centers are the largest consumer of
hard drives that contain elements like
neodymium and dysprosium
these are the same elements that have a
role in the components of electric cars
and there's a great article to check out
if you want to learn more
leaving layers five and six is arguably
more difficult than entering as each
person must exit through full metal
detection and detailed examination and
fun fact google cloud also employs the
security testing program where
undercover actors are in our employ
attempting to bring hardware out of the
data center
this helps us constantly test and
improve our physical data center
security techniques
we actually run dozens of these drills a
year paying unannounced skilled
adversaries to try to get past controls
by any means necessary except for
violence and this includes fake badges
social engineering fake ups trucks
ladder trucks to get over the fence
people hidden in trucks
attempts and thick fog
everything and we usually win
after every attempt we actually run a
blameless post-mortem to improve and
make the next attempt even harder
and we ensure the strength of our
security controls and iterate controls
as needed
this is all about building a culture of
security
all right so these layers don't stop at
the physical layer they extend into our
technology stack that supports google
cloud products too
so at google cloud we provide
capabilities and assistance across
google cloud workspace and connected
devices that cover the whole scope of
responsibility we have a number of
native security features that help
protect you from vulnerabilities like
encryption in transit and at rest and
our hardware infrastructure is custom
designed
our servers don't include any
unnecessary components like video cards
or peripheral interconnects that can
introduce any vulnerabilities
and the same goes for software including
low-level software and our os which is a
stripped-down hardened version of linux
further we also design and include
hardware specifically for security like
titan our custom security chip that we
use to establish a hardware route of
trust in our servers and peripherals we
build our network hardware and software
to improve performance as well as
security
so on google cloud
what's the best way to approach security
well cloud security is a shared
responsibility depending on what cloud
service you're using google cloud will
manage various parts of security above
what we ensure through our secure
infrastructure
so customers are responsible for
securing their own workloads to meet
their requirements and complaints
when it comes to cloud security best
practices there are two sides to it
preventative and architectural controls
which are implemented through
architecture and policy decisions and
first we're going to cover architectural
controls which include the communication
between services how you structure your
resources on google cloud and
permissions and then i'll quickly cover
detective controls which use monitoring
capabilities to look for drift anomalous
or malicious behavior as it happens
let's talk about our approach to
security tooling on google cloud
we have layers of security products and
blueprints for you to quickly get
started here so from the bottom up we
have a global scale
technical infrastructure that's designed
to provide security throughout the
entire information processing life cycle
at google and this infrastructure
provides secure deployment of services
secure storage of data
secure storage with end user privacy
safeguards secure communications between
services and also secure private
communications with customers over the
internet as well as safe operation by
administrators
building on top of the secured core
infrastructure the next layer is the
security products like security command
center premium which is our security and
risk management platform and assured
workloads for securing your government
workloads which enable you to secure
your deployments
these form the lowest levels of the
security stack and then on top of this
baseline are security foundations
blueprints these are security blueprints
which include google cloud security best
practices that are embedded within them
so our goal here is to make it much
easier for you to
start and operate securely on google
cloud they actually enable you to jump
start your deployments by handling some
of your key advanced needs without your
teams
you know first needing to take time out
and learn all of the advanced skills
they help you set up org policies as a
resource hierarchy networking access
logging
detective controls and then posture
blueprints which cover specific sets of
services and workloads
blueprints also come in three tiers
which differ in their level of native
support and lifecycle management
supported blueprints are created by the
google security teams and managed as
products which are regular refreshes and
attestation and testing of the
functionality
and resilience they're all verified so
blueprints can be created by google
teams or partner teams or even customer
teams and the key is that the life cycle
management and attestation of fit for
purpose is the responsibility of the
creating team and today they're offered
via terraform
so compatible blueprints can be created
by anyone the requirement is just that
they need to be correctly formatted to
operate through the blueprint tool
chains
and we also have blueprints that address
specific use cases like protecting
storage buckets or doing um you know
protecting bigquery users ai notebooks
or anthos even so the topmost layer here
is comprised
also of your own web app and api
protection services analytics or even
high performance computing environments
so the security foundations blueprints
provides a strong starting point for
customers to build and deploy
their organization so customers have
access to the opinionated guide of the
full terror form repo of automation
scripts to deploy the foundational
landing zone and it can be deployed
either at the full or level or at the
folder level in the hierarchy
these blueprints provide an opinionated
vetting pattern for resource hierarchy
org policies iam separation of duties
network architecture data access
segmentation
logging and detective controls across
projects and accounts so that way you
can meet your security and compliance
and have a starting point and then you
can also start to build your own
workloads and projects on top
it provides the foundation upon which
you can further deploy an increasing
number of opinionated google created
security posture blueprints for specific
products sets of services and workloads
and we update these blueprints on a
six-month cycle we also provide a
project factory terraform module that
enables you to set the parameters and
constraints for projects when they are
created
you can access the latest reference
guide pdf and the terraform scripts repo
from the google cloud security best
practices resource center and here in
addition to the curated set of google
cloud security blueprints you can also
access both the google beyond prod paper
which lays out the principles and
practices of google google's approach
for cloud native security and how we
think about and how we operate cloud
native
for customers who want to dive deeper
into the knowledge and experience that
google has then the resource center also
includes a link to our building security
and reliable systems reference book
additionally a range of detailed
background white papers
around our reference materials is
available to customers from that
resource center and it covers topics
like infrastructure design and how
encryption at rest and in transit are
handled on google cloud
on the preventative side we also
launched security command center this is
the canonical security and risk database
for google cloud
so it includes a risk dashboard
and analytics system for surfacing
understanding and remediating google
cloud security and data risk across your
organization
so this means from one dashboard you can
uncover common web application and
vulnerabilities like cross-site
scripting or outdated libraries in your
web applications running on app engine
gke and compute engine
and you can also detect threats using
logs running in google cloud or common
container attacks including suspicious
binary or suspicious library and reverse
shell
security health analytics is a
vulnerability dashboard here and it
helps you view security
misconfigurations by severity compliance
standards or project end
you can take action from there
so with this
you can take inventory of your google
cloud assets and partner solutions you
can also understand exactly what changed
in your asset history in near real time
and respond to the most pressing issues
first
you can also receive notifications about
new findings or updates to findings
within minutes and be able to take
action
and also you can identify security
misconfigurations in your google cloud
assets and resolve them by following
actionable recommendations that they
actually have there
lastly you can catch web vulnerabilities
before they hit production and reduce
your exposure to risks and identify
compliance so see violations in your
google cloud assets and resolve them
with these recommendations
and of course you want to be able to
export them so you can export compliance
reports to ensure all your resources are
meeting your compliance requirements
we have support for combined standards
like payment card industry which is pci
the international organization for
standardization iso there's national
institute of standards and technology
nist and the center for internet
security cis 1 and 1.1
and benchmarks
this industry-leading threat
intelligence detects threats using logs
running in google cloud at scale and it
also uses kernel level instrumentation
to identify potential compromises of
containers
and lastly combines threat intelligence
from first and third party providers to
better protect your enterprise from
costly and high-risk threats
thank you so much for joining this
session i know there's a lot packed in
there so i hope you found it as much of
an adventure as it felt like to go
through it if you do want to learn more
check out the resources that will
include for this session and always feel
free to reach out to me on social like
on twitter at steph r underscore wong
thanks again
you